don't come in and just say I want to
raise I just think that coming in and
dropping it like that just always
creates a situation where your leader
could feel very defensive and they're
trying to how do I answer that they want
to have time to figure that out so what
I would come in and say I would just say
this
over the last five years these evals I'm
getting the three percent bump it's come
to my attention I've done the research
I've got friends and people that work at
other organizations don't mention
anybody internally just like this is
what I've seen out there in the
marketplace
and I want to get there
and so the question is
can we come to some sort of agreement on
how I can get there I'd like to get
there now
but I also know that you've got to
measure my performance I just don't want
to make demands I want to make a request
do you see the difference